Sensation and perception closing points. Humans have five sense organs, eyes,
ears, nose, skin and tongue. These have evolved in humans and all animals to
take in information from the outside world, and to allow the animal to adapt
and respond to an ever-changing world. All sensory information gets translated
from physical stimulation to neural information in the sense organs. From
there, they get relayed by neurons to different parts of the brain where that
information is interpreted and made sense of. The senses (sensation) and the
brain (perception and thought) are part of the same process. Responding
adaptively to our environment. It is also important to know and understand that
our sense organs are limited and so we only take in part of the physical world.
So, we never perceive the world as it is but only how our sense organs sense it
and our brains perceive it.